[Music]
Mike Bailey thank you so much for
joining me from Israel in these
difficult times but I'm I'm looking
forward to sharing the story of of apple
seeds and what what we're all doing here
H during during the war and uh share a
little bit about the the initiative but
also specifically about what's happening
now so thank you very much for joining
me how are you it's a pleasure to be
with you and actually it's nice to speak
about something a bit positive during
these very difficult times as you
mentioned so thank you for enabling me
to do that I want wonderful I very much
appreciate it tell me a little bit about
yourself and a little bit about apple
seeds as an organization and then I'd
love to dive into what's happening today
absolutely so I come from the social
World from the social active world I
worked for a big fundraising
Organization for 22 years today I'm a
consultant on different matters
including diaspora development and such
but I know the social field in Israel
very very well and 20 years ago I was
very fortunate to be invited to join the
board of Apple Seeds
Academy in my previous capacity as a as
a member of this organization and we
established together a very very
interesting project called Neta which is
part of apple seeds and we might talk
about it because it's relevant also for
these days and for 20 years I've been a
member of the board seen the development
of uh Apple's Academy into amazing
NGO uh which does amazing work and which
I'll be happy to tell you about yeah
tell me a little bit about the work of
apple seeds regardless of the of the
conflict for a second so apple seeds was
established uh um 23 years ago and the
idea was back then when startup nation
was really picking up and and we started
to understand that Israel is heading in
a very positive direction when it comes
to Technology Innovation and
Entrepreneurship that some people are
left behind that the locomotive so to
speak is running ahead it's doing
amazingly well and I'm talking 23 years
ago it was just the beginning in many
ways but it was very clear that some of
the uh people sitting in the back are
left behind and the idea of the people
who established it um Leon reti idb and
beny Moran was to see how we can close
the gap how we can try and uh um bring
the people who are Left Behind into the
digital world and those people mainly
live in the periphery not only
Geographic but also social and the
initial thought was to establish
computer rooms you know back then it was
a big thing to have a computer room and
they just built computer rooms and gave
a bit of content but actually the the um
the the hardware was the story W what's
special about apple seed is that it's a
very fast learning organization and
always developing and it coincided with
the spirit of the startup nation and
started to think like a high-tech
company instead of an NGO in a way it's
both and very quickly we we started to
develop tools which are about um
technological professions technological
education values opening up
opportunities for for mainly uh young
adults in the periphery um and that was
a
paradigm shift in our activities uh and
we really since then have evolved many
many times but basically the idea has
remained the same how can we can enable
people who do not have the opportunities
that some Israelis have to join through
the Army through A200 or through their
education or through University to join
the startup Nation how we can help them
be part of this great success uh today
we are uh one of where we are the
largest NGO in Israel that deals with
closing the digital Gap our activities
touch tens of thousands of people maybe
hundreds of thousands of people a year
uh in in a myriad of activities um and I
would say me Focus today on three
Fields one is Youth and education and
when I say education it's about
providing uh an access to programming
and to Cloud to gaming to uh um a
variety of things that kids want to be
want to learn and be part of and that we
do with Children and Youth then we have
a big branch of what we call digital
lifestyle which enables
elderly uh um access to the internet
because since Corona and also during the
war we may talk about it now uh
everything is happening on the phone uh
from Social Security to shopping to
doing uh a bus ticket so uh the elderly
need help they were also left behind so
we're we have um a lot of activity in
that field and the third has to do with
um employment and enabling um um again
people in the periphery mainly access
through boot camps and other tools that
we have to join the high-tech industry
and various capacities so those are our
three uh main
drives um the NGO has grown immensely
it's all over Israel from K all the way
down to aot in many many centers uh um
and it's doing amazing
work I I love it okay so so first of all
huge and and and I love how it ties back
into the sort of the the rise of the
startup nation and and you've been part
of this you know for for years so it's I
I love the the longevity of it and the
impact that it's had across Generations
take me now to October 7 so you know
where where are you in October 7th in
the morning when when everything hits
and and what happens with apple seeds
sort of what what is the what is the
snowball that
ensues
yeah well listen I I was at home natur
it was Shabbat it was a it was a holiday
and uh we were just getting ready for
another peaceful uh Shabbat in Israel
and uh you know if we we tend to wake up
and look at our phone I think that's
today the the normal practice of people
around the world some would say
regrettably um I look at my phone and I
start seeing these very strange pushes
and and notifications that something's
going on and uh the Instinct in Israel
is I mean if you lived in Israel long
enough you've been through several of
these rounds or what we thought of the
these rounds so the instinct is to go to
the television and open it up and see
what's going on and from there it was a
shock that I I can hardly uh describe I
was a child during the
73 uh yonip po War which many people are
trying are comparing because in both
cases the surprise was terrible and the
outcome was
horrendous but I think this is this was
feeling worse in many ways the uh
hopelessness the cries and the and the
the um the television reporters were
reporting way before the Army arrived
and we were getting live broadcasts of
horrendous horrendous things that were
happening atrocities war crimes again
that warning were not it was not clear
but it was very clear that something
went terribly wrong the shock was great
um uh anxiety I mean mean again I'm not
a person who gets anxious quickly but it
was very very very disturbing and um
since then in many ways it only got
worse now apple seeds is part of Israeli
society and so many ways it sits on the
fault lines of Israeli Society we work
with the South we work with the north we
work with Jews we work with Arabs we we
work with young people we work with
young families so everyone was affected
I mean again we it was hard to tell
immediately the the the magnitude of the
impact but uh um now we know it was it
was terrible so first of all we have
people living in the south from our
staff from our team and many many of
them were were hurt I mean we have a
young lady amazing young woman who works
with us her sister and her whole family
with an husband and three children were
were
murdered and so that was right there and
since then of course we've had a lot of
the young people on the Jewish side
called to the Army to do reserve duty um
on the Arab side of course there's a lot
of anxiety as well people are worried
people are deeply Disturbed I mean part
of Apple seed's Credo and code is
coexistence and we work very hard on
that through many many different events
that Israel has been through and we've
been very successful by connecting and
creating a dialogue it's not easy it's
not always easy but we've always
succeeded here the the the the cracks
were were
unbelievable and um of course it also
impacts on the functioning of it's a big
NGO we have a lot of activity but people
are unavailable you know on many many
different ways and everything seemed to
freeze at least for the first few
days
um as happens in Israel it took a few
days to sort of put ourselves together
and grasp the situation and realize we
need to move on it happened on the
national front in in certain ways I mean
I won't give uh High marks to all of our
authorities and and functioning um
Ministries but the Civil Society and the
Army I won't go into that but the Civil
Society rolls to the occasion in such an
amazing way I mean it's inspiring
inspiring despite everything despite the
the the the terrible tragedies and the
on the one hand the hurt the anxiety the
the sadness of it
all uh but Israelis as they do startup
nation and came together on the Civil
side and huge amounts of volunteering
and activities and solving problems I
mean the amazing thing was that on that
Saturday already individuals with
responsibility and courage went and
started to solve problems on the ground
so now the whole Civil Society has risen
to the occasion and apple seeds is part
of
it and so what's been happening with
apple seeds over the last 10 days what
what has been the focus and what are
what were some of the activities that
Apple's have taken part in that are
directly associated with this
yeah so again we we we do what we do and
we we do what we do very well so um in
addition to the fact that many of our
staff are are of course recruited and
are in the Army and uh and have small
children I mean even our CEO anap her
son is in the Army and in a combat unit
so there's a lot of personal stories but
on on an organizational level we decided
to take the tools that we have the axess
that we have the fact that we are
present in the North and the South
that's what we do all the time I mean
yeah
365 days a year we're there in the
Northern and the southern places they
call fak still ashon is a big Center for
us you as kulon has been hit more than
any other place in Israel uh uh from
Rockets So we are there all the time
doing our activity so we took those
places and other places that we have
connections to were very deeply rooted
in in the in those communities and with
those municipalities and so forth and
took the tools that we have okay not all
of them can be of course adjusted to an
emergency situation but enough are and
we've started to um to take those the
the knowledge the the skills and the
staff that we still have available to
activate in three
Fields first of all our youth movement
which I mentioned before which is an
amazing youth movement
organization um which starts with
children moves on to young adults and
then to uh uh people in in their in
their late
teens um and we enabled we have in Neta
we have two uh two Roots one is physical
classrooms where they meet and act and
do all kinds of uh phys study but also
do social activities and we have a
virtual
a classroom for Neta which again started
as a result of Corona we took that uh um
that platform opened it up made it
available contined to feed it and to uh
make sure that it's active so our
members our uh our Neta kids and youth
can be can access it but also children
who had to leave their homes you know
thousands and thousands have been deed
uh and had to run away from their houses
uh those those are the lucky ones okay
that managed to escape um and they are
now in hotels and different places
around Israel with nothing they left
with
nothing so uh the kids are there schools
are closed uh and we made it uh um these
platforms which are educational and fun
and gaming and we have all kinds of
different uh um ways to engage young
people and children and made that
available for everyone and we make sure
that that tool is accessible and and
thousands are using it the other thing
is we took that helpline that we have
that the digital uh lifestyle helpline
and because now again people are shut in
their houses for days people couldn't
leave their house some people couldn't
leave the room they know the protected
What's called the M the protected area
uh especially elderly uh and we uh
reinforc those activities so now we are
we have that hotline people can call we
educate them how to use the phone how to
reach out to Digital Services and we're
talking about elderly children families
again who are far away from home and
need to exess
Services um so from government services
to medicine to food whatever it is we
are enabling that through our our tools
and the last thing that we're doing U
apple seeds has a very uh um through the
years to to keep us agile and to keep us
um connected to what's going on we've
developed an R&D Department okay so as I
said apple seed is very special it sits
it's somewhere it's an NGO non
for-profit socially socially
driven uh but it has a lot of Hightech
uh um values so we've developed sort of
a R&D
Department uh to enable us to develop
our tools and keep them relevant so what
we're doing now this is new for us but
it's very important you know as I said
the social um arena in
Israel has bursted into activity with a
amazing energy but there are a lot of
different initiatives which are not
founded on Solid Ground you know some
people decided we want to give the food
or or clothes or drive down south or
bring up north whatever it is and they
need digital tools they need the
databases they need to manage the the
the huge amount of activity so our R&D
department and people within that
framework are providing technical
support helping them put together
digital platforms to manage the huge
volume of activity so that's what we do
we provide digital tools where they're
needed um and those are the three fields
that we are very active in now uh and
we're also moving ahead on other things
things as things develop and I have to
say Michael we're also thinking already
I know it's very hard to do about the
day after and what will require to sort
of
rebuild
communities and we're thinking where can
we because we it's our home it's our
community in many ways you know we want
to be part of that so we're tell a
little bit about the the the energy in
the organization on you know October 8th
versus October
6th how how is the energy shifting
internally in terms of operationally the
daytoday The Experience listen I would
say it was a curve you know it's like uh
it's October 8th was Devastation I mean
everyone was in shock it wasn't uh
October 6 we were as I said heading into
the heading to the
holiday with a very Very Good Year
behind us and a very promising year
ahead of us as far as activities are
concerned um Saturday
was probably the worst day in Israeli
history um and on the eth we were
shocked on the eth on the ninth I mean
no one knew what's going on uh so it was
total a disconnect but then I would say
as the Civil Society of ready started to
pick up and things listen it's always
connected regretfully to the security
situation and I'm not we're not out of
the woods on any front I want to make it
very clear we're not out of the woods
not in the security not in the economy
and not of the Civil Society there's
still a long way to go regretfully but
that being
said somewhere you know later in the
week when we was clear that we we we
have to get going and so and the
volunteers all around Israel started and
that Israeli Spirit after the initial
shock ignited so then we sort of started
to put on our thinking caps adapt our
programs bring together the little staff
that we still have
available a a not put aside the sadness
not put aside the conflicts not put
aside the difficulties but put them uh
in a box for the time being and start
the activity and now now I would say
listen now we're active which in in a
way it's good uh uh we're doing good
work we're doing important work I mean
not me I'm a member of the board but the
team uh is doing amazing work the the
board is supporting them helping them
think with all the context and so
forth um and there's a sense of of uh
accomplishment and you know the fact
that you managed to pull yourself out of
a deep deep deep hole and uh uh start
doing something which is valuable and
meaningful is very important for morale
first of all it's important to the
people who are helping and but it's also
important for the morale of the team and
for the sense
that the huge effort we put into
building this amazing NGO for peace
times is is proving itself as a very
strong backbone for facing this
adversity amazing um thank you so much
for for the the the Le coverage of both
apple seeds but also you know how the
experience of what what this past 10
days have been like um not only the past
few decades but the past 10 days and you
also I think gave a really good light
and and observation into the the
personal experience as to what you know
what were the sense is like as as a
community as an organization as an
individual and obviously ultimately
focusing on you know where we're at
today how can you take what everything
that you've been doing over the last
decades and channeling it into being
meaningful today but then also thinking
about you know the ne the day after and
um and and very proud to have
organizations like apple seeds as as
part of our country so thank you again
very much for the time and H we'll let
you get back to to the very important
work that you're doing H we're like you
mentioned we're just in the early days
and there's still a long ways to go in
this conflict H so thank you H very much
Mike thank you Michael for spreading the
word and anybody who wants to support
apple seeds website is on there and
we'll be very happy because uh the
activities now are important and so in
the future wonderful thank you very
[Laughter]
much